it's like one of those hot wheels you
pull him back wind him up and then he
just takes off ding-ding-ding welcome
back to the jenna julienne podcast with
marvel's on the table and fortieth dogs
in the brown yeah we got everybody
everyone's nice
once again we're all here funny be
chillin speaking of dogs this episode is
brought to you by the farmers dog
amazing food service for your pet board
certified veterinary nutritionist work
on these recipes that they provide your
dogs you fill out a little questionnaire
and they formulate a meal plan just for
your dogs ship to your door super easy
go to the farmer's dog calm slash
annejulien to get 50% of your first two
weeks and you get free shipping amazing
service also guys Squarespace build your
website Squarespace hey peach you're
gonna have to lay in your bed peach lay
in your bed go go on lay in your bed of
the Squarespace peach Squarespace is an
awesome website building company and
service that allows people who may not
know how to build websites built really
beautiful websites for their small
businesses large businesses personal
hobbies whatever it is amazing customer
support go to squarespace.com slash
annejulien save 10% off your first
purchase or a website or domain hurry
are we ever gonna get them in there I
worked for five seconds nothing wrong
staring at me you have to give them the
Heisman so they don't get up here peach
we can't podcast until y'all lay down
teach in your bed you know what we can
I'm in control that's right we are in
control not them it's something that the
dog trainers been reminding us who's in
control I'm in control you're in control
not you not you you anything you have in
the universe oh wow that's a lot
no that's what she says we are the we
are the God that they worship I don't
know hey peach nope wrong way wrong way
welcome to Jenna and Julian trying to
get dogs to lay in a bed for one
straight hour aka whenever of our life
anyways if you're watching this we are
on vacation for the first time ever it's
so beautiful out today look at look at
this view that we have in our hotel room
I hope it's beautiful I'm so excited
we're gonna be we're gonna be on
vacation while you're watching this
believe it it sounds weird saying I'm
going on vacation yeah cuz I've never
done it but it's a normal thing why
haven't we ever done it I don't know I
don't know I was still kind of guilty
like taking time off er yeah not posting
things I don't know and like we're
better but like the podcast or like a
radio show and that kind of stuff or
this dream but like for my videos I
don't really it's ok hey bud you're good
we're usually pretty decent out like
getting you know staycations or even
like a big bear bombs it's like weekend
and that's always nice it is but we've
never done like a full-on week you know
leave the dogs at home like leave work
at home take a week off and actually
just go have a vacation so we're doing
that and then we're both really excited
yeah can't believe it can't believe it
so no podcast next week because we're
gonna be lounging on vacation but after
that we'll be back are you excited for
what I done did for you what have you
done do for me well it's okay it's
basically 20 questions whatever but it's
called Who am I and because I wrote all
of these out you're going to take an
index card yeah tape it to your forehead
wait does this game exist name Who am I
or did you know it's called Who am I
oh it exists no way I mean away me Who
am I alright and I'm gonna have you take
your headphones off so I can whisper to
those people that are listening and
whisper in my ear yoga Thank You Julian
and then you're gonna guess who you are
the dog in the room that wasn't rescued
from a bad situation is crying when they
play this new game or Jenna pretends
that she's physically rescuing him loose
in the Australian outback her snakes and
spiders oh my god the heat is so high he
has no water I need to find him oh there
you rescue you know like you know like
our game he likes it he's feeling you
know like whenever you get another dog
and your first dog is like what about me
he's feeling extra I'm seeing a marginal
amount of extra crying I feel like his
his crying level has already been pretty
high yeah but his meaty angry and or
resentful glares at me have increased he
does give you quite the look girl
useless a pet me okay so I just don't
look because the market that I use sort
of bled to the other side I write some I
bury some tape so I was there that's it
if you'd like yeah if you'd like to tape
it to your forehead in any fashion you'd
like I would like to don't look but I'm
gonna fan these out and you pick one
okay do it above the table so doesn't
look all sketchy
okay so the back side is facing you so
tape that side to your head is this
right side that's not yes okay oh that's
a good one oh I can't look at the
monitor cuz I don't see are you able to
read that oh don't look at them on it
okay close your eyes and look at the
monitors so they can see are you ready
to play Who am I Who am I
yeah Mehdi okay go ahead Who am I I
can't tell you how to ask yes or no
question yes you have to ask yes or no
question how long have we known
maybe six or seven years got you it
wasn't yes or no question doing use
always start off twenty questions with
do we know where so that he could knock
out whether or not it's a celebrity or
at all about knocking out a lot of
questions in one borderline cheating
[ __ ] alright six or seven years to mail
I think do we see him a lot a lot I'm
gonna say on occasion okay would we
classify him as our best friend yeah
sure
is it Brett no um do we play video games
with them yes Oh is he funny yeah
is he from how to stay yes is he
drivable distance yes is it will
Cheyenne yes I really did i FaceTime him
in bed last night did I FaceTime him in
bed last night
you sure did okay as well damn that was
pretty good yeah that was really
impressed because usually this takes
like this celebrity one the very
difficult for you well no here's where
we run into problems and we've gotten
into like fights before but we have to
stop playing question and it mostly
happens in the car oh I see well
Cheyenne cool mostly happening in the
car but like the issue comes when I pick
a celebrity and you're asking who do
they take as their date to the ball or
whatever questions I don't know are they
married or are they dating someone I
never know no that's not the problem the
problem is that you give me inaccurate
information like you'll pick Madonna and
tell me she's 35 and I'm like thought
she was it's so misleading like I can
never get it right but the part where I
run into most issues is their sex life
okay yeah you say are they dating this
pregnant and they say no but it turns
out they actually are misleading it's
not on purpose
it's
okay pick another one shouts out to will
a boy will dad to pick up the bowl the
table
you're literally okay the truth is
really happening figuratively you picked
to stop it's upsetting
close your eyes and show them are you
gonna are you gonna whisper or that
you're gonna do the whisper oh my bad my
ears did you get headphones off okay
it's bunny okay oh god you scared me I
always like falling asleep
welcome back is it a famous person no
okay are we good friends of them uh yeah
I'd say that okay it's a people don't
know about people know about them but is
he similar in age to us I can only
answer no to that is it a girl yes okay
she is similar in age does no is she
related to one of us hmm
not by blood no she a human being yeah
okay okay she a dog funny when you said
it wasn't a human being I figured it was
probably bunny clap okay you know don't
okay Jesus
I believe that you can just hear no I
know
smash your own ears over and over it's
the loudest sound anyone can ever make
for their on itself oh really
so if you were to like this is louder
okay all right go ahead do it
are we good friends with this person no
we don't have many friends Julian
that's cheating you look up at the crime
you know you can read the writings okay
you've never thought about Jeannie is
she alive Julian is it a girl no is he
alive no you're cheating okay
[Laughter]
is it was it tragic honestly yeah it was
real live when he died I'm saying why
are we alive when he died no is he a
historical figure yeah can he get it
yeah okay yeah so he's got a wagon we
got that way is he an American man no oh
got that foreign wagon what that was
just the that was me thinking out loud
okay see European no was he wait
I don't think so have you ever seen a
picture of his face
yeah was he alive when pictures were
taken No Oh Napoleon no he was he was
white yeah I think so but I don't know
did he is he viewed in a positive light
yeah
was he murdered yeah was he tall you
know I don't know the answer to that
what the [ __ ] I'm sorry
was he in a war no well no was he an
entertainer no was he white Julien I
already answered that so no no you can
do it I'm lost
you said he's viewed in a positive light
mm-hmm
did he die when our parents were alive
no when their parents were alive okay
we're not gonna do this we already
established there weren't pictures oh
yeah that's right is he of any
significance of to you or me personally
oh yeah oh really
yeah was he
wait was he was he an explorer no what's
he on TV wait that was that's wrong
no I only asked three oh okay have you
used this name in 20 questions before
yeah and it took you like seven times as
long as this time to get it Road Trip
and it took Julian like two hours to get
Jesus good job okay hey don't throw that
on the ground okay thank you for that
Julian I can't hear what I sound like so
I'm just gonna be cool okay all right
close your ears slap your ears it's okay
okay
is this person the same sex as you know
is he famous
yes close your eyes and look at the
monitor okay did I do that already
mm-hmm he is famous yeah okay is he life
mm-hmm do you make music yeah primarily
yeah how do you know that you like his
music are you cheating no yeah I like
his music
are you election in my glass try to do
that to me tell me if that's possible I
can't see without my glasses okay put a
card up I'm gonna go I'm gonna pick one
okay we have different classes
my glasses no it doesn't work like that
if anything there's a window behind you
but I'm not looking at it I swear to God
I stopped cheating I'd literally quite
literally just said I'm not cheating
okay so he's alive he makes music and we
like his music yeah is he hot really
yeah is he younger than us no oh you
must be hot really uh is he married no
actually I don't know but I don't think
so
smoldering smoldering when's last have
we listened to a song of his this week
hmm you know I don't know the answer to
this is it pop top 40 yeah oh yeah um is
he white no it's multiple genres some of
which is pop top 40 okay
is he black
no okay huh have we ever met him yes is
it pitbull yes oh my god I am a legend I
am a legend Dolly I told you smoldering
hot stop it get some help he is older
than and Wow that was a good one in case
you didn't know Jenna was in his
fireball me like you I'm just gonna like
blast put her on blast real quick
stop blasting you're somehow embarrass
of it but I think it's super dope it was
blown like the night we got Peter shoot
he came with us yeah and her little baby
blanket yeah you picked chill
I didn't
okay make noise again with your ears
okay it's that if you like I'm on a
roller coaster amazing is it a girl no
is he alive yeah do we know him yeah
do we play video games to them no is he
your age no is he older than you
no okay is he related to one of us no
wait he's famous yeah he's younger than
you and famous
we know mm-hmm huh as you do what we do
similar mm-hmm okay
is he friends more with me I don't know
do we see him regularly not regularly to
assume have we seen him in like the last
three months I don't think in the last
three months
do we see me like events yeah see a
youtuber yeah is he funny yeah is he
from the US yes huh I don't know any us
youtubers okay well then I guess we're
done here
does he have colored hair he has I think
yes he has he does currently have color
no oh he has in the past does he sing
yeah sceneries I don't know if he's an
Aries look at her not giving me
information when I don't claim to any
questions okay you know egg he does have
a pig mm-hmm we've been a guest on this
podcast
it doesn't narrow it down that much I
know a lot of people of pigs correction
he is an Aries and it's rickey dillion
is he an Aries Wow it was really
impressive
good job I brought my a-game a stands
for Aries
I think it might be the first time in in
actual history that I knew someone's
astrological sign before me yeah yeah I
would agree with that
Kermit just go ahead Julian okay it's
upside down again okay you're good a lot
of guessing mm-hmm it's quite tiring I'm
sorry I could use a meal and if I was a
dog that meal would be the fun of the
dog the farmer's dog is a really great
service that allows you to customize
meal plans for your pet
based on their eating habits their
choice in food their size and their goal
weight if you have an adjustment that
you'd like to make actually I'd like to
say farmer's dog has been a big reason
why peach has lost some weight and she's
currently still losing weight because
we're you know we're walking her a lot
and we're getting her down to herd like
ideal goal weight for her breed the
farmers dog is really great so I called
them the other day and I was like hey
when we started with you guys peach she
was a lot larger and we had a different
goal weight for her because we were just
trying to like slowly lose weight but
now that she's lost the way we want to
get her down to the ideal weight can you
adjust her meal plan and they were so
amazing so helpful it worked with me on
the phone they're like yeah no problem
basically what we'll do is cuz I told
him that we feed Kermit and peach
together they're like we'll combine
their food so you don't worry about
double packaging and you're just gonna
feed them a little bit less and they
come with the exact instructions of how
much of the pouch you feed them how many
times a day it was just really pleasant
customer customer service experience
like you don't get that a lot but if
you're interested in trying new food for
your dog and you're wondering well well
my dog like it the answer is yes dogs
love it they lose their mind for that
food even Bobby even marbles he's gets
so excited at Meal Time you basically
fill out a little questionnaire about
your dog like I said about their size
eating habits food preferences things
like that
and what they do and then you can sign
up for a specific meal plan that you'd
like whether you want to deliver every
two weeks or every month or and they
send you a box of freeze-dried it's
amazing these pouches but it's fresh
food and so then you get it and you feed
your dog and that's it you don't have to
go shopping for dog food it's amazing
our dogs love it and right now you can
get fifty percent off your first two
week trial of fresh healthy food at the
farmer's dog calm slash annejulien or
click the link down in the script
description below I'm telling you guys
you will not be disappointed but more
importantly your pet will not be
disappointed
also Squarespace over 200,000 companies
use square species you know that to make
their websites it's pretty amazing
pretty amazing that's a lot of websites
a lot of websites and you could be one
of them I have personally worked with
Squarespace on websites and it is just
so crazy easy it is nice you can make
all sorts of different alterations and
customizations to your website to make
it look exactly how you want this is
weird I can't hear myself I'm sorry
also and speaking of customer service
like in farmers log nobody's better than
Squarespace they have 24 hours a day 7
days a week customer service no matter
what you're doing what time of the day
you're doing it if you need help
building your website on Squarespace
they're they're there for you they can
talk to you and help you it's such a
good feeling to have that support when
you're trying to do something that's as
daunting as building a website honestly
if you need your whether it's for your
small business or your your photography
or whatever it is anything that you want
to build a website for doesn't have to
be anything specific literally whatever
you want Squarespace is there to help
you reach your potential right now go to
squarespace.com slash Jen and Jillian
save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or domain or just try with a
free trial either way click the link
down below and give it a shot Thank You
Squarespace Thank You Stacey farmers dog
all right Julie get cracking boy all
right now so far nothing girl right ok
yes girl see what you did there
see that didn't count you just looked at
you're selling into Lensbaby okay baby
all right get going stop chugging water
guess do we know Am I do we know her
yeah we know where do we know me yes I'd
be doing it in the first person share it
do it do we know me yeah
am i hot it's so hot am i real am I
related no I'm not related to one of you
for me okay we want am i our age no am i
famous am I in one of our families yeah
am i older than us no am ia human no yes
yes he hot so and she got that way you
less of a wagon though right
you go don't look okay don't do things
without looking don't look all right
stop looking in the window I haven't
looked at it once I swear to god I'm not
cheating why don't you just look down a
bunch of times as you lied at me okay
good good is this person famous yes
Barry have they been on Ellen what are
these are they're famous they are I
can't be famous in Bonanno linen they
have never been on Ellen loser yeah
loser
[Laughter]
[Music]
have we established if it's a male or
female no we have yeah she our age
roughly know roughly not
would she have been on Ellen
absolutely was she a musician no which
was she alive in last hundred years I'm
gonna have to look it up because I
honestly don't know the year but was she
an actress no was she in entertainment
no was she an American yes
was she in politics she she was alive in
the last hundred years
okay is she was he black no was she
known for anything regarding politics no
was she an author no was she she was
famous yeah she human yeah was she on TV
no she doesn't do music she's not an
entertainment she wasn't on TV she's not
in politics she an athlete no that's all
the things I know okay she was alive
last hundred years mm-hmm
did she die suddenly mm-hmm why you
smiling dark oh I'm sorry was she killed
yeah Oh not murdered but she dies he
said what she killed like someone else
yes that's with kill means no not by
someone else okay when someone dies of
old age you don't say that guy was
killed
okay wait come on okay so they were
killed by old age or something of like
no don't I don't I honestly don't know
what other walk
life they would have been famous for mmm
no author no author that's not what
she's famous for was she famous what she
did was for one event mm-hmm Oh was she
white mm-hmm hmm was the event did have
to do with yeah the year she died was
1937 what's the first letter of her
first name no what is their stuff named
after her
probably was she Jewish I don't know the
answer to that god I'm lost
could she how you say get it okay I'm
like an answer that I'm not gonna answer
that
yeah I kind of want to just throw in the
towel like I don't know she was a pilot
Monte Amelia it's auntie Amelia Amelia
Earhart how could you I'm sorry
wait so so in your mind she was famous
because she crashed her plane and never
was found no she was a pilot but you
said she was famous from one event yeah
us if she's an author and athlete I'm
sure she was probably both of those
things on the side as well but why
wouldn't you answer if she could get it
or not because it just it feels weird
dude did I ask about Alan for that one
yes yeah for sure
she probably wanted okay I don't want to
keep making jokes about him I mean she
passed away it's sad I wanted to make
jokes without probably offensive okay
here you go Julian why don't you pick
him up good work and she is or not she
is our aunt it's upside down all right
cover your ears Julia Roberts welcome
back am i hot mm-hmm my life yeah am i
nearby no what I don't know do I live in
the area I don't know maybe do we know
him
okay tell me that's do we know me no
okay do we watch me on TV no do we do we
do anything similar no job absolutely
not
am i older than you yeah am i much older
than you mm-hmm I don't know how much
much is my Hollywood actor yes my white
yeah my handsome no my sex symbol sure
it's um not handsome but I am a sex
mm-hmm
have I been in movies yes have I sold
out theaters probably a mic still making
blockbusters yeah why don't about
blockbusters but films yeah do you think
someone's probably called me daddy at
one point
no no not once anywhere no one's called
me daddy and I'm somehow a sex symbol
probably not once more than once then no
never probably not ever
so I'm near an age to us older than us
not crazy no I never said near you said
I said I'm much older than you said no
no way said I don't know how much much
is okay much is like 25 years older yeah
I'm 25 years older than you hmm am i I'm
still doing it is he funny am i funny
yeah you're funny
wait a minute am i Nick Cage I was in
the cage I'm sorry but you're wrong I've
called Nick Nick Nick Cage daddy okay
wonderful wonderful for all of you she's
not Kathy pace so I'm funny
yeah okay am i primarily in comedy
movies mm-hmm all different kinds of
movies at this point have I just like
throwing the time I'm just like [ __ ] it
I'll take whatever now no mm-hmm okay so
I'm a versatile actor mm-hmm am I like
have I won an Academy Award
I don't really answer to that and I
don't think that that will help you I
don't know did you have kids yeah how
many I don't know the answer to that and
I don't think it's gonna help usually
are they doing pretty good I'm gonna
shut my eyes and look at the monitor
that was it I want to give the camera
some face time okay all right hmm
it's like some vital question really
yeah am I married to a famous person yes
my bad no I know that's why I don't know
what you're asking stuff like that
that's not gonna help you yeah an arena
of what I should be asking point me to
the arena why don't you ask what their
gender is already yes it's a guy no I
never said it's a guy I've been guessing
guys this whole time I know so it's a
girl yes oh that's why it's not Nic Cage
that's why they haven't been called
daddy how they been called mommy
probably a lot okay
mamacita okay you know what um so the
other said Jennifer Aniston mm-hmm do I
like this person yeah do I confuse them
with another person yes truly Rob is
Julia Roberts
oh she's daddy she can get it okay she
all three of them can get it wonderful
all three of Julia Roberts can you
imagine walking up to like Anne Hathaway
or Sandra Bullock and be like oh my god
Julia Roberts that's pretty intense I'll
do it I know you would because you
genuinely wouldn't know
however many you want this one's kind of
hard is it mm-hmm is this person alive
yes
is this person a male yes this person
famous yeah is this person online not
more than anyone else my profession
would actor no is this person older than
us mm-hmm older there are parents not
older than our parents mm-hmm okay so
between us of our parents or just around
the same age as our parents probably
they're famous yeah and there are they
are the entertainment yeah okay are they
on TV yeah they were
I don't think so anymore as much do they
have a later show no who were they in
scripted television no were they in news
no were they reality TV yes no not as
much do I know of this person yes is
this person a comedian no was this
person a host no not really
but sort of was this personal on MTV no
what so they were in reality TV mm-hmm
was it cooking no good question though
was it singing no was was it America's
Funniest Home Videos no is that real
let's step backwards oh so not Bob Saget
Bob Saget all right I had to clear out
the Saget okay cool is he problematic
you know is he funny yeah he is mm-hmm
so he was in reality TV he's not anymore
mm-hmm wasn't cooking as much that I
know of was he a contestant on
show no he was like a host I said he's
like oh but not the host mm-hmm was he
like the co-host or like no way
something like that but not the host was
the show was it a sports show no but it
was a competition well it was a
competition it wasn't singing wasn't
cooking wasn't sports singing cooking
sports was it beauty no fashion yes okay
is it Tim Gunn yeah that was like the
first legitimate round that you played
Julian
oh my god my actual father I know he's
everyone's father - ends right yes nice
that was the only round you played for
real and then just asked do they have
that wagon and can they get it okay well
you never know when knowing if someone
has a distinguishable wagon will help me
okay you know keep making the noise sure
I have my eyes shut and my all of my
sent my senses are blocked and you scare
me like scare you
am i one of our family members no am i a
human yes am i alive
yes female yes female human alive and my
famous yes am i around take one guess
now that you've heard the things we're
just guessing the dark I'm famous I'm a
girl I'm alive yeah boom who is it
let's see if we can do it via telepathy
ready go Oprah guess let's try again
three are you giving me numbers I'm
trying to get the name of a person yes
hi
no that's not a person are they things
online no not by profession are they our
age
no no actress oh yeah better actress
than Meryl Streep answer's no doesn't
exist
well she's other things too Oh singer
yeah blonde sometimes no not a bad guess
sometimes blonde are they do they dye
their hair a lot they don't know not not
as much anymore but they have or wigs um
do you like their music yeah is it
really good hell yeah
sure it is sure all of a sudden when you
said hell yeah I was like Jenna only
likes one person's music with a hell in
front of it and it's share and also the
wood the wigs thing or they're not the
wakes thing the color of the hair thing
cousin stuck on you her mane her Mane
debut in Hollywood she had a number of
different hairstyles in that one movie
have we watched stuck on you recently
Julianne I'm not gonna watch that movie
I might hop on rabbit you guys want to
watch - I'm not gonna watch that movie
Julianne pick a card
folding table Who am I Who am I
alright that's upside down but I will
tell them
what it is as soon as you close the ears
I stopped early because I was trying to
defend myself I promise I hear he said
oh okay I'm trusting you was I mean okay
is this person an actor no are they a
man no are they alive yes are they
famous yeah female famous being a female
famous alive
how healthy are they probably doing
pretty great famous are they not
traditionally famous what does that mean
are they online yeah no no well I guess
in theory X finer but now on tick tock
what X finer now on tick tock it's a
girl
mm-hmm she has one very famous fine but
I don't think she's the one that posted
it is it the country boy I love you you
wrote country boy I'll uh let the girl
from the vine country boy I love you and
then is that Alan it's just a squiggle
Wow I gave you a lot of hints but I'll
accept it we can do however many more
you want one more good one all right
I'll give you one then give me ya hand
pick a good one let's end on a good one
okay there you go is this right mm-hmm
okay
Who am I all right you need to show them
I'm gonna tell them Who am I I don't
know you tell me
am i alive yes sure mm-hmm
do do we know me mm-hmm why music
drumming music they have like that
Justin Timberlake no am I an athlete
yeah for famous no am i wouldn't buy one
of our friends yeah really yeah my
friend more than yours probably okay I
feel like it's free straight for do we
play video games of this person yeah
this is this person own yeah right way I
make music am I like an online person
mind yeah do I wait give me a hint
no come on no okay we're getting
somewhere
was this person at my birthday party
yeah ok cya just like going on the list
[ __ ] okay
was it well you already did well Caleb
no Matt no Chris no Shan no that's a
girl Lexi no mr. marbles
no human yeah Jeff no
am I missing someone mm-hmm no not
mm-hmm what are you doing what do you
mean I don't miss anyone those are all
the guests of the party except for me
and me yeah it's me this is just barking
in her sleep I can't believe you picked
me sorry sorry I feel bad we startled
her no we didn't she was having a
nightmare
that's all you heard her growling first
she's like when they have dreams that
you barked herself awake yeah a home
poor dog so it's like so adorable look
it's like anyway thank you for picking
names and coming up with this game this
is actually kind of fun
Who am I okay go ahead hello welcome
back to the gym I'm so good I can hear
my voice again is this one I sound like
oh wait so you said I had a wagon yeah
that's right
good game friend good game good game
friend well did you enjoy yourself
I really did it's fine I think if we
take like a light-hearted approach to
this game it's always fun mm-hmm once we
get a little trihard it's over it's over
over once you want to win and I want to
win and it's over mm-hmm so just let's
just do it like that from now on Who am
I Who am I Who am I I can't believe you
did I mean the Earhart and Jesus
those are like I'm sorry go does to all
the time in this I'm sorry it's fun also
I guess Sharon I'm proud of
yeah I'm proud of you too strain you got
Tim Gunn which I'm very impressed with
well you're not surprised no not really
you love him don't we all we all do how
could you know do we have any Content
shoutouts this week have you seen
anything on the internet that you care
to mention I'm trying to think if I have
I can't think of anything on the top of
my head I haven't been writing them down
have been a little distracted you know
we've been so like everything just
revolves around bunny which is what we
want but it's just yeah trying to think
if I I saw something here you can throw
this out wait what I don't want Merry
Christmas
no pushes nightmare again all right well
I guess that's it I try to think about
have any content okay fine geez all
right
well we'll be gone next week hope you
guys have a wonderful week no streams
this week nine-nine it's crazy that's
gonna go that's gonna be the I feel like
the most bizarre change yeah there's
like no streams all week but it'll pass
and we'll have a good week and then
we'll be back on the internet and stuff
next week so thank you guys for all the
episodes that we've done without taking
a single vacation and for allowing us to
take a vacation yeah I'm excited very
excited thank you for being here thank
you for listening and watching we'll see
you guys on the next one in two weeks
have a great week we love you
[Music]
you
[Music]